music music music You know that often, often, when I'm driving on Sunday night to our Sunday night dinner that we all do together with our fans and stuff, I'll rock out to Duran Duran. I'll rock out to hungry like the wolf. You have to film that next time. As I'm driving through the hills, it makes me feel good.
That's why you always walk in with a glow stick between your teeth. That's why I'm always wearing like pastels under a blazer with shoulder pads. That's why you walk in with two hookers on either side of you. By the way, speaking of walk, I am my hamstring. I'm having major hamstring issues. Yeah, when did this start and why? I don't know. I think it's, I hate to say, I think it's golf related.
It's a golf injury. That's up here with a sleeping injury. Well, Jason, you had your back golf injury last week. Right. But I usually hurt my back doing things like tying my shoes or tallying off after a shower. We've come to that year. Tallying somebody off after a shower? Or just myself.
Oh, okay. I don't know. Because I'm a little wet right now if you want to just drive me up for like, wait, Jay, how long do you have? Wait a second. We're going to clip that for sure. I'm a little wet right now. Well, I meant from the shower, from the shower, water.
So Jason, how long do you have to stop playing golf for your back to get better? It's been a week and today I'm going to break the mold. It's been a week back. Week back. It's raining. No, it stopped. Take a look. I have a window in my room.
No, it's going to be a shit day. You're going to have a terrible day and you're going to re-break your back. It's my prediction. I'm doing prediction, but the hamstrings suck. How do you hurt your hamstrings playing golf? You know what? It's been a nagging thing that's been kind of, I've had it sort of strained a few times over the last two years.
Is it a disc thing in your back that goes down to your... I don't think so. I think it's an actual just hamstring thing and I think that's probably a non-properly stretching thing and I do a lot of, I do that hill. If we were smart, if we were smart, the three of us being of a certain age, right, more than 50, we would do the thing that we hate, which is yoga. If we did yoga, we would have such a more pleasant aging process. I think.
I used to, one of the best, but it's the same as yoga a little bit, but Pilates. I did Pilates about 10 years ago for about six months. In addition to the regular sort of working out, I did that, I was stacking, before stacking was the thing, I was stacking. It was great. I felt so much better doing that. I know, but it takes a lot of discipline to... And also, I can't stand sweating because I'm stretching.
It's like being stuck in a hot car with windows that won't come down and a door lock that is broken. It's like, can I, with no sweating, I want to be doing something active. I feel the same, I feel the same way. Except not when you're in the sauna, you're sweating and you're not active. That's true. That's the sort of a contradiction that for some reason I'm okay with because it's just. But like if you're moving furniture or doing like a strenuous activity or something, you're
sweating, I get really irritable fast. Yes. Yeah. I always feel like, and this is going to be controversial, but oftentimes it reminds me of like when I'm in England and it's cool out and I feel like everywhere inside is very stuffy and hot. I always feel like I'm wearing a jacket and then I'm inside and I'm just, and it's stuffy inside.
How about in Europe, if you look at Jason's face. Every time you're in England, what foot do you work for the government, what are you talking about? What are you in England? I spent a lot of time in England. How about, wait, how about when you're in England or Europe or whatever and you ask for a Coca-Cola, they don't give you ice and it's like 110 out. I don't know how they've never experimented with how things taste better with ice, carbonated
beverages. It's true. I used to put ice in my beer. You've never experimented with it. I mean like it's indisputable that a room temperature Coca-Cola tastes world's worst. I was in a restaurant once and it was in Italy and it was quite warm out and I said, can I get a Coke and the guy brought me a warm Coke and I looked at him and I said, do you want me to barf?
I mean, hey guy, I don't understand it. But anyway, I don't know, anyway, it's a long way from there from my hamstring, but I do have it wrapped right now. Did you go to the doctor? No, doctor. You wrapped it yourself? Yeah. Well, yeah, I wrapped it myself.
I mean, hey guy, I don't understand it. But anyway, I don't know, anyway, it's a long way from there from my hamstring, but I do have it wrapped right now. Did you go to the doctor? No, doctor. You wrapped it yourself? Yeah. Well, yeah, I wrapped it yourself.
Yeah, it is. He wraps. I didn't have some. I want to wrap it now. My name is Will. My name is Will with a W before the XYZ and after the TNU. You know? Oh, wait.
Hang on a sec, Sean. I think what we've just stumbled on here is a wrap that Will has always had since he was a kid. And there's probably music that goes with it. Oh my God. Now, would you like us to do the beat? My name is Will with a W before the XYZ after the TNU. You hear my deaf rhyme.
It's coming prime time. No. How many times have the boys heard that on the way to school? What do you mean, write it? I just said it. He grabs the microphone, too, like he's shaking a hand. But you put effort into that. No, I didn't.
No, no, no. I think I wrote. I said it out loud once in the car, and then I just said it to my students, like a dumbest freestyle of all time. At some point, Sean, we're going to get into your pop career, but somebody's got to. Somebody's definitely got to, but I'm too hamstrung to do it. I tell you who's not hamstrung. I tell you who's not hamstrung.
This is a segue. This is a really good segue. I feel like my segues are getting worse. I was going to say better, but now I think about it, this seems like they're worse. You know, I'm not hamstrung by the talent of our guest, and neither is he. This person is kind of known for his voice. In a way, and he's been known for his voice for so long in so many iconic ways. This is one of my bucket list guests who I have not stopped talking about and quoting
and singing and listening to and type for years and years and years. I've bored you guys with it, and I've just always wanted to know they played. He has played such a huge part in my musical experience throughout my life in so many different ways and different incarnations. Boney Vare. Again, one of our guests who, once I start to list things off, you're just going to immediately know who it is, even though you guys already heard. He has done it all.
He's an Englishman who, along with his buddies, Nick Rhodes and John Taylor, decided to create a little band called Duran Duran at Simon Le Bon. What? Will, how do you do it, Will? Oh, my God. Oh, that's so cool. Come on, you fellas. Nice to meet you.
Now, Simon, how do you know Will Arnett? Will, how do you know Simon? I mean, I know you're a fan of Simon. That's a great question. It's completely irrelevant because we don't know each other. That's right. They just, I just got a call from the production company offering me a huge, obscene amount of money to do your podcast.
How come they pay me that much? How can they possibly make a treat? It's out of my own pocket. I went, I went out of my own pocket for this. I, Simon, I've been trying to get you on the podcast since we started. I've, we've had to cut out clips of your music just because of publishing and royalties reasons. I would constantly come on to the show playing Duran Duran.
I'm such a massive fan. We all are massive fans. Yeah, huge. It's such an honor to have you. I've seen you in concert like two or three times and it just blows me away every time. So Simon Le Bon. We're coming back. You know, we're back on tour in America this year.
Well, don't, don't push it. You've got it. I'm not trying to flog it to you. I'm coming. I'll come. Are you playing at the Tabasco Theater? Are we? No, that's where Sean is.
Do you mean I've got to look at my itinerary? No, no, no. We, Sean is playing at the Belasco Theater. His new play, Good Night Oscar, opens in April at the Belasco Theater. Oh, the Belasco. Oh, the Belasco. Not the Tabasco. On Broadway.
Which Jason was just being cheeky, as you might say. We have played at the Belasco. Have you? And New York? And also, and it's next door to the Mayan, isn't it? I've never been there. I leave in a week. I think it's next door.
We've played at both the Belasco and the Mayan Theater downtown LA or is it downtown or is it sort of? No, this is in New York. Are we played at the other Belasco? Right. Yeah. The Annex. The Bolasco too.
Okay. The Bolasco too. You've played everywhere. You have a new record and you guys are going on tour last year and you did some dates at, did you do four shows at the Hollywood Bowl? Am I right about that? We did three. Three.
Three amazing shows. The first one, it was absolutely pissing with rain. Really? Oh, really? And it was, but rain shows are always special ones. But in Los Angeles, rain falls like chemicals from the sky for people in Los Angeles. Everybody scurries. Everybody runs around with their tongue sticking out.
People just don't know what to do with it. I always say that rain in LA is a chance for all the people on the west side to get out their fancy all-weather clothing. Get to accessorize. It starts to drizzle and people have their great boots and their fucking hoodie and coat. And the safari vehicle and the snow tires. Just to make it to Trader Joe's. The safari vehicle with the snow tires on the chains come out and a rhubar on the front.
So, Simon, we, and we're going to get into how you guys became what you became and who you became in terms of, you know, musically and what an influence you are. But I kind of want to, I want to get back to the start because I know so little about it. I want to know, first of all, it's just so thrilling, it's such an unbelievable thrill. You started as an actor. You went to drama school. Is that right?
Well, I started as an acting student, as a student actor. Yeah. I mean, I had a few roles. I did a few things. I was more of an advert kid, you know, I did like personal adverts. That's like washing powder. I did a few commercials and I did a run at a theater in the West End when I was a teenager. Yeah, but I was an aspiring actor and I went to, I went to university and I studied acting.
That's so crazy. I never knew that. And at the same time, I met a bunch of guys called Gerand Gerand who were looking for, wait for it, a lead singer. Yeah. And I had had, I had had my own punk band. Well, me and my three mates, we'd had a punk band. Back in Pinner, the little suburban town that I grew up in.
Yeah. And, and I fitted right into Gerand Gerand and that was the end of- Well, how did you know you could sing? Like, how did you audition for it? Well, because I was always a singer. Oh, you were always a singer too? Yeah, I was, I was singing from, from the cradle. I sang in church choir.
I used to do singing competitions. I got a guitar and I started to talk myself to play guitar. Well, actually, no, Mr. Shuri, the folk, the folk guitarist who gave 10 lessons at the school I went to taught me how to play guitar. And I learned the rest of it. I learned to play slow down, you move too fast, you got to make the morning last just kicking down the cobblestone, looking for fun and feeling groovy. That's the reach right there.
If you can hit that, then you can pick the right. You're one of those few singers too, because of the training and stuff. And I said this to another friend of mine, a friend of mine that sings, you have the proper training to know how to use it so you can tour and you can do night after night and you can sing properly, as they say, where other people who don't scream lose their voice and they don't know how to take care of it. Isn't that true? Well, I make no mistake.
I used to go out on tour and scream and lose my voice. I think we all did, a lot of us did in the early days, mainly because, because we didn't have ear monitors, so we were competing with the guitar. You can only turn the vocal monitors up so loud before they start feeding back. So there's a point at which you can't amplify the voice on the stage any higher. And of course, the guitar can just get louder and louder and louder and louder until the only way you can hear yourself singing is if you shriek your head off. We were also, also don't forget, in a lot of places, we were competing with, you know,
tens of thousands of screaming teenagers, many of them female, with very loud, high voices. And one in the way back. And then they're shy. And one bloke. That was you, was it? And one young... I bet you had a great time.
With a smoky eye. Yeah. He was ready. We just come from behind the soda machine, from a make-out session with another guy. But wait. So Simon, by the way, were you always like... It's true, by the way. He was true.
Were you giving sort of shitty glances over to the guy who was an Andy Taylor on guitar at that point? Were you kind of like, hey, man, tone it down or...? Yeah, well, I mean, I knew that it wouldn't make any difference what I said to him. So, honestly, you know... I love learning what the ear monitor is for. Because I feel like that's a recent thing, those ones that are formed right to your ear, like that's over the last, like, 10 years.
Well, the first time, no, they're older than that. You'd be surprised. The first time we went on tour and I had ear monitors was 1993. 1993? 1993. So we've had them for 30 years. When you first got it, were you like, oh, man, this is... Yeah.
Yeah. It was extraordinary. I could turn the guitar down, so there was nothing at all in my ears. And then, of course, you know, if you take all the other instruments out, you sing out of tune, so that's no good. But I found, you know, you've learned to make a really good balance of the things that are in your head. And it works.
And it is much easier to save your voice. What's more satisfying when a huge crowd starts singing the words that you're singing, like they know the song, they love the song, or when they're completely silent and they're just totally engaged and you have them in the palm of your hand and they're listening to you doing your great singing. Like, I've always wondered that. Well, the way you put it makes it sound a little egotistical. Me listening.
You can listen to my great singing. This is a safe zone. This is a safe zone. So it's not really like that. But what they do, really, is that they sing along with the big old favourite songs, songs like Hungry Like the Wolf, Planet Earth, Come Undone, Every World. And the list does go on. It does, man.
They sing along with those ones. But when we play new music, especially sort of like the new ballads and things, so off our latest album, which by the way is entitled Future Past, that's when they listen because they're not so familiar with the songs. So you get that chance with the new album, with the new material, you get that chance to just for them to hear it the way you want them to hear it. And we will be right back. Startless listener, we get support from Zip Recruiter.
I can juggle. That's a talent that I have that not a lot of people know. Also I can, well, nothing. But you know what? From soft skills to hard skills, it takes all kinds of talent to make a business successful. If you're hiring and you want to find the right combination of talent for your open rules, you need Zip Recruiter. And right now you can try it for free at ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless.
Zip Recruiter uses powerful technology to find and send you people whose skills and experience match your job. If you see someone you're really interested in, Zip Recruiter lets you easily invite them to apply to your job, to increase your chances of getting them before your competition does. So if somebody was looking for a guy in his early 50s who can kind of juggle, you know, and they connect to me, you know, and I don't know if anybody's looking for it. The point is, tap into Zip Recruiter's unmatched talent for finding great candidates, four out of five employers who post on Zip Recruiter get a quality candidate within the first day.
First day. See for yourself. Go to this exclusive web address to try Zip Recruiter for free, ZipRecruiter.com slash smartless. Again, that's ZipRecruiter.com slash S-M-A-R-T-L-E-S-S, Zip Recruiter, the smartest way to hire. We get support from Benjamin Moore. So recently, one of our producers, Rob and his wife, Drea, have been doing a little bit of sprucing up around their home.
And one of the projects they just started working on is refinishing their backyard deck and their front gate, just in time for backyard summer hangouts. God, that sounds nice. Enter Benjamin Moore Paints. By the way, did you know that painting your deck will last years longer than just staining it? Me neither. Anyway, they picked out a bunch of swatches from their local paint shop, Charming Little
Spot called Jill's Paints in Atwater Village. And they ended up using a specialized floor and patio paint for their deck that holds up to foot traffic and the elements. And for the gate, they use Benjamin Moore's Heritage Line, which is formulated specifically for exteriors. And a result, both look absolutely stunning. Also compared to paint shopping and a giant home improvement store where it can take ages to get some assistance, this was a breeze.
And they got to meet local business owners who happened to be super friendly and helpful. With Benjamin Moore's premium colors, you can just, you see the difference. They have a whole team dedicated to ensuring best-in-class formulations that are better, stronger, and simpler. Benjamin Moore Paints is only sold at locally owned stores. Save 15% off on your next paint or sample purchase at benjaminmoore.com using Code Smartless. That's benjaminmoore.com, Code Smartless. We get support from Storyworth.
You know, Mother's Day is coming up and I love my mom. I really do. And I love her so much I call her mom, but that's just because I'm Canadian. The point is Mother's Day is coming up and I'm thinking of different ways that I can show my mom that I love her. And if you want to make Mother's Day extra special, gift something that's really unique. Storyworth is an online service that helps you and your loved ones preserve precious memories and stories for years to come.
Every week, Storyworth will email your loved one a thought-provoking question of your choice from their vast pool of options. These are questions you may never have had the chance to ask, like, I don't know, what's the bravest thing you've ever done in your life? And after one year, your loved one's stories, including photos, will be compiled into a beautiful keepsake book that you'll be able to share and revisit for generations to come. For me, the idea of being able to preserve these moments and these thoughts and this real connection with my mom to be able to have that forever is amazing and not just
for me and my relationship with my mom, but also for my kids to be able to look at, for the whole family and to share with my siblings, it's just, I don't know, it's something that's really, really special and really unique and it's more than just something that you could go out and buy for them, which I'm not poo-pooing, I'm just saying this makes it really personal and a real connection. Of all the moms in your life, a unique heartfelt gift you'll all cherish for years, Storyworth. Right now, for limited time, you'll save $10 on your first purchase when you go to storyworth.com slash smartless.
That's S-T-O-R-Y-W-O-R-T-H.com slash smartless to save $10 on your first purchase, storyworth.com slash smartless. And now, back to the show. Can I ask a dumb question? Duran Duran means what? Well, it's like Smith Smith. Duran is the most, is the most common name in France. Well, it's the second most common name, actually, because the most common one is Dupont.
But we didn't like the sound of Dupont-Dupont. Right. Duran, Duran, Duran, I'm looking for Duran, Duran from Planet Earth. So you... That was Jane Fonda. I'm looking for Duran, Duran from Planet Earth. Duran, Duran from Planet Earth. Yes, Duran, Duran from Planet Earth.
From which we got the band name and the name of our first single. Gotcha. Huh. And the name of your first record, Duran, Duran, obviously, and your... was Planet Earth the first single from... Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
We didn't... I didn't actually take that from the Rajivadeem film, Barbaraella. You did not. No, it was only afterwards when we watched the film again that we realized that the title of our first single was in it. It was a wonderful coincidence. Mm-hmm. Yeah, because that's the character's name in the film, right?
So Milo O'Shea played a character called Duran, Duran, and he had done... He'd done a bit of a... He was a scientist, but he'd done a naughty bunk with some kind of pleasure machine. And also this deadly weapon called the positronic ray. Anyway, this old pervert back on the Earth Foundation got the youngest, most attractive astronaut, which is Jane Fonda, as Barbaraella, to go out and find it. I've kind of seen this movie. I've heard about it for years.
It's a wonderful film. If you haven't watched it recently, watch it. What's the name of the movie? Barbaraella. It's called Barbaraella. Yeah. You've heard of it, right, Sean? It's a very famous film.
Yeah, of course. And then Kamie Anderson remade it, I think. Did she really? Did she? I don't know. Maybe I got that wrong. Maybe it was a different girl's name. Chances are high.
Chances are high that Sean just likes to throw things out there. So Simon, so you do it so... And the character's name was Drendd Drendd, right? If I'm not mistaken, with the D on the other hand? Is it? I think so. But anyway, which gives you even more... Disappointments.
No, no, I'm sorry to... Oh, my gosh. Oh, well, you know, you know, because John and Nick were sitting there, sir, in their Birmingham living room watching the movie, and all they could hear was Duran Duran, sir. Right. So that was the name of the band at the time. So you guys formed Duran Duran, Planet Earth, a big hit. And then if I'm not mistaken, was Girls on Film also on that first record?
I think it was. Yeah. Yeah, it was. Yeah. And you guys, that was one of... That video, and I don't know if you guys remember, that video was like really too hot for American audiences. Oh, yeah.
Yes, I remember that. Right? Walk us through that. What we did was we made two versions of that video. And it was Kevin Godley and Lowell Cream were the video directors. We made one version, which was quite tame, and you could put it on MTV during sort of, you know, sort of family hours. And then the other version, the night version, which it was a longer video, and we actually
wrote an extended piece of music for it. That was... You could only see that on video jukeboxes. Oh, wow. In America, video jukeboxes, in nightclubs around the United States. And speaking of which, night versions, you guys actually, and I found this out just, you guys went and remixed all your own songs and did night versions so that they...am I right about that?
No, we didn't remix them. We re-recorded them. So we actually recorded longer versions. We didn't just cut and paste the...which you couldn't do that anyway. Right. Because it was all on tape, it was all on magnetic tape. We didn't try to kind of copy anything and stick it on later. We wrote 12-minute versions of the song, of all the songs that we did night versions
of. So that it would lend itself better to sort of dance clubs and whatnot, as opposed to... Yeah, because that was the only way we could do it. That was the only way we knew how to make long versions, 12-inch records, was to go back in and record them as 12-inches. Isn't that amazing? And so they have this whole, you can go and you can look it up and they've got all the release of all these night versions of these extended versions that I did not know that
you re-wrote and re-recorded, which is pretty heavy lifting. I know, but it was...that was just the job that was...the job that there was to do. And if you listen to the girls on film version, the girls on film night version, it has a completely different last verse. Oh, really? Yeah, it goes...how's it go? God. Take one last glimpse into the night, I'm touching close, I'm holding right, shudders
in a whisper, I'm coming closer, take me high till I'm shooting a star. Oh, wow. And it was more like...sharing a star! That's the backup section. Sorry, Mum, am I going on a bit too long? Did you...did you...I've always wanted to know, whose laugh is at the beginning of Hungry Like The Wolf, which is one of my favourite intros to a song ever? Yeah, that actually was...it was a girlfriend, her name was Cheryl, she was my girlfriend,
and then funny things that happened in this life, she became Nick's girlfriend. No way. No way. What happened? I would imagine that's not the only time that happened, you guys have been together for quite some time. Really? Okay, we're going to move right along now.
Speaking of being together for a long, long time, you guys have been making music for so long and been relevant for so long and been able to do what it is you want to do for so long for such a great big audience. What is the process of staying true to where you guys want to go, changing your musical sound and having that kind of progress, and then also trying to stay as aware of and is in touch with as possible what the changing of music is in popular music, you know, like there was a time when it was all the music...the instruments were plugged in and then they were not plugged in and then there was more like, you know, how does that go?
Or do you guys just make music for you and hope it catches on? I think you've got to...there's a couple of ground rules here. Number one is you can't follow trends. You can't be following a trend as your major kind of writing inspiration. That cannot be your major inspiration. You have to make music that you like, that you enjoy, otherwise there will be no passion in it and people can hear, they can hear the difference between something that you really mean and something that you're just going through the motions with.
And I...but also I think you've got to be aware of where music is at the moment, I mean, and I think...and we all are, and we always have been. We...you know, there's stuff that we did in the 1980s, we never dream of doing now because it just wouldn't be relevant to us now. What do you do when your taste in where things have gone is not aligned with your band mates? What is that kind of creative negotiation like, was you guys are starting to work out a new song? Well, you know, there has been times when somebody's gone in the studio, laid down some
parts and somebody's come in after them and laid down completely contradicting parts that don't work with the ones that went down before. The strong usually survives. The... That'd be the strong music or the strong personality? Yeah, the strong...the strong...oh, the music, definitely the music. And what are the politics of that like, like sort of navigating that within the band? Well, nobody's got any...no, there's nobody who's more...whose opinion is more important
than anybody else's. Yeah, you have. You know, we don't have... It's got to be hard though. And, you know, when you went off and did...went solo on projects, I've always wondered, what is that dynamic? How do you have that conversation like, guys, I love you, but I'm going to go do this for a second.
Do they have any animosity here? Well, none of us have really gone solo. Oh, I thought you had solo stuff. No, not really. I mean, I've done a couple of...I've done a couple of things. Nick and I did the Arcadia project. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. John and Andy did the Power Station project.
Power Station. That's right, Power Station. And Roger, God bless him, he did drums on both projects. Oh, wow, okay. So he was a...he's the only guy who was in both Power Station and Arcadia. Yeah, I love both. By the way, the fact that you guys weren't named the Taylors is incredible, considering there...it's Roger, Andy and John.
Taylor Taylor. Yeah. All unrelated. Unrelated, yeah. That is my Taylor Taylor. Yeah. So you guys do...you guys do...you and Nick do the Arcadia thing. Those guys go and do Power Station.
泰勒·泰勒。对。全都没有关系。没有关系，对。那才是我的泰勒·泰勒。对。所以你们……你们……你和尼克搞了“阿卡迪亚”乐队。那些人去搞了“发电站”乐队。
And then that...and then sort of five years later, you guys...you do the wedding album? Is that right? No. It wasn't quite like that. So in the last...we did...we did Seven O'Ragga Tiger, went on tour throughout sort of 84. And we...then we got back together and we did View to a Kill. Oh, yes. Yeah.
然后在那之后……然后大概五年后，你们……你们做了《婚礼专辑》？是这样吗？不是。当时倒不是那样的。所以在最后……我们做了……我们做了《七和弦老虎》，在84年左右进行了巡演。然后我们……然后我们又聚到一起，做了《杀人执照》。哦，是的。对。
And that was the last recording that the original five members made before the hiatus and the Power Station and Arcadia. Then Power Station and Arcadia happened. And then we got back together, but in the Getting Back Together, it turned out that ultimately we would only have...well, not ultimately. But when we tried to get back together to reconvene the original Joanne Joanne, we weren't able to get Andy Taylor back in the band, really, and definitely weren't able to get Roger Taylor back.
那也是最初五位成员在暂时解散以及“发电站”和“阿卡迪亚”成立之前录制的最后一张唱片。然后“发电站”和“阿卡迪亚”就成立了。之后我们重新聚首，但在重新聚首的过程中，结果发现我们最终只有……好吧，也不是最终。但当我们试图重新聚首、重组最初的杜兰杜兰乐队时，我们真的没能让安迪·泰勒回到乐队，而且绝对没能让罗杰·泰勒回来。
So Andy was kind of in it and kind of out of it. Roger was definitely out of it. And sort of after a while, we realized that it would be, you know, it'd be me and Nick and John. Andy wasn't going to be a guitarist and Roger was not going to be our drummer. So we looked for other guys to work with. And quite happily, we really kind of developed our friendship and working relationship with Niall Rogers at that time.
所以安迪算是进进出出。罗杰是绝对不回来了。然后过了一段时间，我们意识到，你知道的，就只剩下我和尼克还有约翰了。安迪不会当吉他手，罗杰也不会当我们的鼓手。所以我们寻找其他人合作。非常高兴的是，当时我们真的和奈尔·罗杰斯发展出了友谊和工作关系。
And that's when we kind of had the Notorious album. That's when that's what that was what made that. Is there a story you can share that you're comfortable sharing about why those two guys weren't able to come back in that new incarnation? Well, yeah, sure, Roger, he really had his he it all became a bit too much for Roger. I don't know the I don't know the exact term for the the sort of the psychological problem that he was having, you know, it wasn't a nervous breakdown. It was it was but it something happened to him and it and the anxiety was too much for
然后我们就推出了《声名狼藉》这张专辑。那就是当时的情况。有没有什么你可以分享的、而且你也愿意分享的故事，关于为什么那两个人没能回到那个新组合中？哦，是的，当然，罗杰，他真的是……这一切对罗杰来说有点太沉重了。我不知道……我不知道他当时经历的那种心理问题的确切术语是什么，你知道的，那不是精神崩溃。那是……但他的确发生了某些事情，焦虑感对他来说太重了
him. And he wasn't able to carry on with the band. And Andy just wanted to be a rock and roller. And he just didn't think that Gerand Gerand was the right vehicle for the kind of music he wanted to make at that time. You know, he went off and he recorded the band Thunder. And he did he did some of his own rock records, heavy sort of American style rock record. Whereas we wanted to be Gerand, the rest of us wanted to be Gerand Gerand.
以至于他无法继续留在乐队里。而安迪只想当个摇滚乐手。他只是觉得杜兰杜兰并不是他当时想做的那种音乐的合适载体。你知道的，他单飞去录制了“雷霆”乐队的专辑。他还做了一些他自己的摇滚唱片，那种重金属风格的美式摇滚唱片。而我们想成为杜兰，我们其余的人想成为杜兰杜兰。
Yeah. Yeah, I have a question about touring like because I think people when people go see a live show, they're, you know, and they go nuts for you guys. And then the show's over, they go home and they're like, what an incredible show. Not realizing you have to do it night after night after night after night or sometimes with just a little break in between. What do you do to get ready for a tour because I can't imagine how grueling that is on your voice on your body on your sleep schedule and like the food that you have to like you
对。对，我有一个关于巡演的问题，因为我认为当人们去看现场演出时，他们，你知道的，会为你们疯狂。然后演出结束了，他们回家后会想，多棒的一场演出啊。却没有意识到你们得日复一日、夜以继日地不断演出，有时中间只有一点点休息时间。你们为了巡演要做哪些准备，因为我无法想象这对你们的嗓子、身体、睡眠时间以及你们不得不吃的食物来说有多么折磨，你们
just have to maintain all of that. And second part is, you know, I live for horrific live stories like what's the worst that a fan did, like, did they rush to stage and something happened or I love those kinds of stories if you're having. Right. Just let me just try and just put two in there. Just go ahead and take the first one and let's do the first one, which is with the first part of that question was, was what do you have to do to kind of get ready for a tour?
必须维持好这一切。第二部分是，你知道的，我特别喜欢那些骇人听闻的现场故事，比如粉丝做过最糟糕的事是什么，比如他们有没有冲上台发生过什么，我超级喜欢那种故事，如果你有的话。好。就让我试着……把两个问题放进里面。先回答第一个吧，我们就从第一个问题开始，也就是那道问题的第一部分是，为了准备巡演，你们必须做些什么？
Yeah. Well, we rehearse, but I think, but you know, we made like physically and mentally. Yeah, well, physically, we try not to leave it too long between shows. So we had a before we had, even though it was a little one, we had a performance at New Year in Times Square, and that kind of just keeps just keeps you nudging that nudging your personal fitness up. And we're ready. We're going back out again in April.
对。嗯，我们会排练，但我觉得，不过你知道的，我们要从身体和精神上做好准备。对，身体上，我们尽量不在演出之间隔太长时间。所以在我们……在我们有一次演出之前，哪怕那只是一场小型演出，我们在时代广场跨了年，那种感觉就像是……能不断推动你、提升你的个人体能。我们就准备好了。我们四月份又要出发了。
So we'll be rehearsing before that. And we'll all be physically capable of the job of doing the job, probably psychologically. I mean, just once you get to a certain kind of state in your career and you and you and you know that the heart, the more you try, the harder it is. So you need to just go up there and just do it and not and not and not try too hard. It's a bit like, you know, hitting a tennis ball or a golf ball or a cricket ball or even a baseball. Let's say, you know, it's that relaxed swing that has gives you the best results and performing
所以在那之前我们会进行排练。我们从体能上都能胜任这份工作，可能心理上也是。我的意思是，一旦你的职业生涯达到某种状态，而且你……而且你明白，你越是努力，事情反而越艰难。所以你需要做的只是走上台去，然后把它完成，不要……不要……不要用力过猛。这有点像，你知道的，击打网球、高尔夫球、板球甚至棒球。打个比方，你知道的，那种放松的挥杆才能带给你最好的结果，而表演
is a bit like that. You've got to be relaxed, but but but accurate. And to do that, you've got to be confident. You've got to really believe in yourself and believe that you can do it. And yeah, because you're going from just, you know, not running around the stage for a year or whatever to mounting a tour to all of a sudden, I have to run around the stage and you have to keep that endurance up. It's just got to be, I can't imagine.
也有点像那样。你必须保持放松，但……但要准确。要做到这一点，你必须自信。你必须真正相信自己，相信自己能够做到。而且，是的，因为你要从整整一年左右不怎么在舞台上跑来跑去，突然转变成要展开一场巡演，以至于你突然必须在舞台上奔跑，你必须维持住那种耐力。那简直……我无法想象。
You had to do it. I mean, you were on Broadway. You did it. Yeah. A couple of musicals. Yeah. And it's yeah. That's why I ask is because while I'm gearing up to do it again and it's, you know, mentally
你必须这么做。我的意思是，你曾在百老汇演出过。你做过。对。出演过几部音乐剧。对。所以……这就是我为什么要问，因为当我正准备再次投入其中时，从精神上来说
just have to. Tabasco. Can I ask you a question? Do you suffer from nerves? Oh God. Yeah. So I have something for you. I have something for you.
你只需要……塔巴斯科辣酱。我能问你个问题吗？你会有怯场的困扰吗？哦天哪。对。那我有个东西要送给你。我有个东西要送给你。
This is my gift to you. It's my litany against nerves and it goes like this. It's not fear. It's adrenaline. It's just your mind and your body preparing you to do something extraordinary and you will do something extraordinary. Yeah. I love that.
这是我送给你的礼物。这是我的“抗怯场经”，它是这样的：这不是恐惧。这是肾上腺素。这只是你的心灵和身体在让你为做一些非凡的事情做准备，而你也必将做出一番非凡的成就。对。我太喜欢这个了。
Amen. God, if you're at home, record that and pay that back for yourself. I love that too. Honestly, it makes such a difference when you, when you, and you realize I'm not frightened. It's just the, it's just the butterflies. It's just the side effects of me sharpening up. Did you, did you, did you have those, but like when you guys, when you started, you released Duran Duran sort of in the early 80s, those first, I don't know, five years
阿门。天哪，如果你正在家里听，把这段录下来，放给自己听。我也太喜欢这个了。老实说，当你……当你意识到“我不是害怕，这只是……这只是紧张，这只是我进入状态的副作用”时，真的会有完全不同的感受。你们……你们在刚出道的时候，当你们发行了杜兰杜兰乐队的专辑，在80年代初，那前，我不知道，五年
of the 80s, 80 through 85, maybe the most in demand band in the world. It must have been like, you just rocket it up. All your records were, were, were top of the pops and you had so many singles and you're on tour all the time. Did you have time in that? Were you young enough to not be nervous and just to be fucking cocky and just, I mean, I was, I, I, I got nerves. I've been nervous with every single performance I've done, but I've learned to cope with it.
也就是80年到85年间，你们可能是世界上最受欢迎的乐队。那一定就像……你们简直是一飞冲天。你们所有的唱片都……都……都登上了排行榜榜首，你们有那么多单曲，而且一直在巡演。在那段时间里，你们有时间……你们当时足够年轻，所以不会感到紧张，只会变得他妈的傲慢自大，就只想……我的意思是，我……我……我也会怯场。我经历过的每一次演出都会感到紧张，但我已经学会了去应对它。
And I've always, and also when, when the music starts and you walk on stage, the nerves becomes, it's almost, it's more like that little shower that you go through on the way to the swimming pool. And the hygiene shower that, well, they spray you with sulfuric acid. That's what they do in this country. That it's, it's, you know, you walk through it. It's like a, it's like a shower bath that you walk through and you come out and you walk on stage and the music starts and the nerves just, you just, they just recede into the,
而且我一直……还有当音乐响起、你走上舞台时，紧张感就变成了……它更像是你在去游泳池的路上必须穿过的那一小阵淋浴。那个消毒淋浴，嗯，他们会用硫酸喷你。在这个国家他们就是这么干的。那就是……那就是，你知道的，你从那儿穿过去。它就像是一个……就像是一个你走过去的淋浴间，然后你出来，走上舞台，音乐响起，紧张感就……它们只是退回到
into the darker back part of your brain. And suddenly you're there with the music and the audience. And that's in a way that the importance of that overcomes all the rest of it. One of the other things that I would think that you would need and want is the, is the desire to be out there and to be playing the same set every night, could get monotonous, same thing with theater, right? Sean, were you doing the same material every night? How do you find the excitement to do it as good as, or if not better than last night?
你大脑较深的后半部分。突然之间，你就和音乐以及观众融为一体了。从某种意义上说，这种体验的重要性战胜了其他所有一切。另一个我想你会需要也想要的东西是，那种想要置身其中、每晚演奏同一套歌单的渴望，因为那可能会变得单调乏味，戏剧演出也是如此，对吧？肖恩，你是不是每晚都在表演同一套素材？你怎么能找到那种兴奋感，把它演得和昨晚一样好，甚至比昨晚更好？
It's a good question. It's a really good question. Are you, are you channeling into the audience? There's more to it. No, no. No, I think what it is, is, I think this, it's, so you have to, the audience is part of it, I think, because that's the audience is one time to see you on that tour. Maybe they won't come, they maybe they, maybe some of them will come back next tour, very,
这是一个好问题。真的是个好问题。你是把这种情绪传导给观众吗？不仅如此。不，不。不，我认为原因在于，我认为……所以你必须……观众是其中的一部分，我认为，因为那是观众在那次巡演中唯一一次看你演出。也许他们不会来，也许他们……也许他们当中有些人会在下次巡演时回来，但极
a few of them will come and see more shows on that tour. But for most of the people in that room, it's their one time seeing Gerand Gerand maybe for two or three years, four years, five years. Maybe the only time in their lives they can see Gerand Gerand. And, and you just remember that they are, they deserve the best show they can get. And then you start to, then you, then you let the music, you just have to give yourself to the music. I've got another, another, I've got a little mantra before I go on stage as well.
少数人会在这场巡演中多看几场演出。但对于那个房间里的大多数人来说，这是他们两三年、四年、五年里唯一一次看杜兰杜兰演出。也许是他们一生中唯一一次看杜兰杜兰演出。而且，你只要记住，他们值得看到你们能呈现出的最好的演出。然后你就开始……然后你……然后你让音乐……你只需要把自己交给音乐。我在上台前也有另一个……另一个小口诀。
And that is, let the songs do the work. I don't have to go out there and give a performance. I have to let the, I just have to serve the songs. And then everything else about the performance falls into place. And when you do that, and the music, the music has got a great way of putting you right in the moment. And you're not thinking about what you're going to go and have for dinner in a restaurant after the show.
那就是，让歌曲去完成工作。我不需要走上台去卖力表演。我必须让……我只需要服务于歌曲。然后关于表演的其他一切都会水到渠成。当你这样做的时候，音乐……音乐有一种绝妙的方式，能把你直接带入当下。而你不会去想演出结束后你要去餐厅吃什么晚饭。
And you're not thinking about what somebody said to you back in the, back in the hotel or something else. You become very much in the moment. And when you're in the moment, you can't be bored because every little thing that you're doing is so important that it's, you, you, you're, as I said, you're serving the songs, you're doing the best you can to, to deliver these really good songs in the best way they could be, could be present. I'm the opposite.
你也不会去想刚才在酒店房间里某人对你说了什么或者别的事。你会非常专注于当下。当你专注于当下时，你就不可能会感到无聊，因为你所做的每一件小事都是那么重要，以至于你……正如我所说，你在服务于歌曲，你在尽自己最大的努力，以这些好歌能够被呈现出的最好方式来演绎它们。我恰恰相反。
When I'm on stage and doing a play or a musical and it's, and it's performance, you know, 135, I'm completely thinking about what I'm having for dinner later. All right. I know it does happen. And it's, it's, that's the, we call that autopilot, right? Yeah. Yeah. For sure.
当我在舞台上出演话剧或音乐剧，而且已经是第135场演出时，我满脑子都在想待会儿吃什么晚饭。好吧。我知道这确实会发生。而且……这就是我们所说的主驾驶自动巡航，对吧？对。对。肯定的。
You just go on to auto. That's when it's time to move on. And there's no difference. How, how involved are you in another part of the shows that I always love in any rock show is, is the, is, is the show around it, the lighting, the stage work. Well, I was going to get to that, Jason. Do you know that these guys, I mean, Simon, you guys were one of the first acts to really incorporate the video aspect of the show, right?
你直接开启了自动模式。那就该是时候翻篇了。而且毫无疑问，在演出的其他方面——我一直很喜欢任何摇滚演出中的那些环节——就是围绕演出展开的灯光和舞台设计，你参与其中有多深？我正要说到这个，杰森。你知道这些家伙，我的意思是，西蒙，你们是最早将视频视觉效果融入演出的艺人之一，对吧？
You guys. We, we, we were the first act to use a video wall behind us. Wow. Yeah. Wow. We're very involved in it. We, we work with the, with the designer. We've got a fantastic guy called Vince who, he's an amazing designer, I mean, amazing
你们。我们……我们是第一个在身后使用巨型视频墙的艺人。哇。真的。哇。我们深度参与其中。我们与……与设计师合作。我们有一个名叫文斯的了不起的家伙，他是一位惊艳的设计师，我是说，他设计了令人惊叹的
sets and lighting and he, he does that, but we're sitting with him on, in all the way up to the, the production rehearsals, looking at the stuff he's doing, because he's always redoing it and, and, and developing it. And the imagery, the actual images. Oh yeah. Absolutely. And that's, that's another thing. The synchronization of that with the music, with the, when you're going to go with the
布景和灯光，这些都是他做的，但我们会和他坐在一起，一直到制作彩排的整个过程里，看着他制作的东西，因为他总是在重新制作、不断改进。还有那些意象，那些实际的画面。哦，是的。绝对的。这也是另一个方面。将其与音乐同步，在你要配合
upbeat or the outer, whatever the heck all that stuff is. Do you remember, do you remember the reflex that the video for that was like from a concert and used the, the video wall and then like the, and had that sort of that image of the wave. Yeah, Simon. Yeah. Yeah. Right.
强拍或副歌时切入，不管这到底是怎么弄的。你还记得……你还记得《Reflex》那首歌的MV吗，里面有演唱会的画面，用到了视频墙，然后还有……还有那种海浪的意象。对，西蒙。对。对。没错。
The wave that came out of the video, at the top of the video screen and the one guy in the audience who got a bucket of water thrown in his face. Yeah. Yeah. I remember that. But it worked. Yeah. It worked.
海浪从视频里涌出来，从视频屏幕的顶端涌出来，还有观众席里有个家伙脸上被泼了一桶水。对。对。我记得那个。但效果很好。对。效果很好。
Yeah. And people, people came up to me, people were coming up to me in, in, in, you know, in, in the street or in shops. I'd be, I'd be, I'd go out to like record shops in Toronto and somebody comes say, hey, that, that screen, how did you make the water come out of the video screen? Because they were, they were so taken in by the effects that they really thought it was real. Yeah.
对。而且人们……人们会走过来，人们会在……你知道的，在街上或商店里走过来对我说。我当时会……我会去多伦多的唱片店之类的，然后有人会走过来说，嘿，那个屏幕，你是怎么让水从视频屏幕里涌出来的？因为他们……他们被那些特效深深吸引了，以至于他们真的以为那是真的。对。
Of course they did. And of course now we watch it. So compared to modern CGI, it's, it's obviously very fake. That was me. I was the guy in Toronto. Oh, that was you. Yeah. Who came up to you.
他们当然会这么想。当然，现在我们回看它，跟现代的CGI相比，它显然非常假。那个人就是我。我就是多伦多那个家伙。哦，原来是你。对。向你走过去的那个人。
I was living in Toronto. I thought I recognized you. Yeah. Yeah. And I kind of remember that so vividly. That video was so huge. And the other thing I want to know in that time, so you do all these great things and then walk me through a little bit getting the phone, the call from Bob Geldof to appear
我当时住在多伦多。我觉得我认出你了。对。对。而且我把那一幕记得清清楚楚。那个MV的影响力太大了。另一件我想在那个时期了解的事是，既然你们做成了所有这些伟大的事，那么能跟我简单讲讲接到鲍勃·格eldof打来的电话、邀请你们参与
because I played it a little bit in our intro. Oh, that's what you're playing. Yeah. And do they know it's Christmas? Yeah. One of my, I have tried to, I've bastardized what you do, but I love your solo at the beginning of that. It's so fucking good.
时的情景吗，因为我在开场白里放了一点。哦，原来你放的是那个。对。就是《他们知道今天是圣诞节吗？》对。我尝试过……我模仿过你们的表演，但我太喜欢你那首歌开头的solo了。太他妈棒了。
He has literally sung that a thousand times. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. What, what, what was that like, that process of getting Bob calling you? I was at home and I got a phone call and Bob goes, Simon, did you see it last night? I said, well, Bob, he says, the African thing. I said, no, I didn't see it, Bob.
他 literalmente 已经唱过那一千遍了。对。对。对。那个……接到鲍勃电话的过程是怎样的？我当时在家，然后接到了一个电话，鲍勃说：“西蒙，你看到昨晚的节目了吗？”我说：“嗯，鲍勃……”他说：“就是关于非洲那个事。”我说：“不，我没看，鲍勃。”
He says, it's terrible. He says in Africa, in Ethiopia, they're starving and dying. I want to, I want to, I want to do something about it. And I thought we could make a record. We could all make a record together. Would you be up for being on that record? I said, yeah, absolutely. And then, and then, and Bob later told me that he called two people.
他说：“太惨了。埃塞俄比亚那里的人们正在挨饿、正在死去。我想……我想做点什么。”我说我们可以出一张唱片。我们可以一起出一张唱片。你愿意加入那张唱片吗？我说：“行，当然愿意。”然后……然后鲍勃后来告诉我，他只打了两个电话。
He called me and he called Sting. And he reckoned that if he got the two of us on it, then everybody else would say yes to it. And this was, you know, you know, all planned. He had the, he had the whole thing planned. I went and did the demo. I went to a little studio. I can't remember where in London and work with Midge Ewer and Bob and did the demo. So when we all arrived at the studio, Sam West, I thought I was singing all of the verses.
他打了给我，还打了给斯汀。他估计只要把我们两个搞定，其他人都会点头答应。而这，你知道的，你知道的……全都是计划好的。他把整件事都计划好了。我去录了小样。我去了一个小录音室，记不清在伦敦哪儿了，和米奇·尤尔还有鲍勃一起录了小样。所以当我们所有人到达录音室时，萨姆·韦斯特，我还以为所有的主歌都由我来唱呢。
Oh my God. What's that, what's that Bono guy doing here? I thought I'm singing that bit. Well, it's funny because it's you and Sting are singing and then, and then all of a sudden when they cut back, Bono's between you and Sting. Yes, that's right. Yes. And then you see like all my God, I remember at the time too, I was such a fan of the jam as well.
哦天哪。那个叫博纳的家伙在那里干什么？我还以为那段归我唱呢。好吧，这很有趣，因为本来是你和斯汀在唱，然后……然后突然之间，镜头切回来时，博纳就站在你和斯汀中间。对，没错。对。然后你会看到……天哪，我当时也记得，我也是“果酱”乐队的超级粉丝。
Paul Weller was just making the move to style council. And I was like, oh my God, fucking Simon Le Bon and Paul Weller and Bono and Sting. And they're all in the same frame. Nobody had ever seen anything. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That was wild. Did you guys, did you feel in the moment how that it was really, could you, did you recognize in that moment, wow, this is something amazing?
保罗·韦勒当时正准备转向“风格理事会”。我就想，哦天哪，他妈的西蒙·勒·邦、保罗·韦勒、博纳和斯汀。他们全在同一个画面里。从来没人见过这样的场面。对，对，对。太疯狂了。你们当时……你们在现场有没有感觉到那种震撼，能不能……你们当时有没有意识到，哇，这是一件了不起的事？
Yeah, because no, no other time had all those, that variety and that number of hugely successful rock stars being in the same room together, doing something like that. Not even on, not even on Saturday morning TV shows. Yeah. You wanted to know, but I remember the story, the absolute worst thing that happened on stage. Yes. Yeah. Well, there's been a few, a few mishaps, but there was one.
对，因为在此之前，从来没有过如此之多、如此成功的摇滚巨星齐聚一堂，去做这样一件事。哪怕是在……哪怕是在周六早上的电视节目里都没有过。你想知道，但我还记得那个故事，就是在舞台上发生的绝对最糟糕的事。对。对。好吧，出过一些……一些小意外，但有一次。
No, I don't know if you know this, but I went commando for 20 years, mainly because I was not kept up to date on that. I'd mentioned throwing a pair of underpants behind the headboard of this hotel that all the bands you sustain and going back there two months later and finding them still there behind the bed. Oh my God. And I was telling this to another rock star and he says, oh my God, I'm shocked. I said, yeah, it's disgusting and he says, not that, you're a rock star.
不，我不知道你知不知道这件事，但我有20年不穿内衣，主要是因为我当时没有跟上潮流。我曾提到过把一条内裤扔在乐队下榻酒店床头板的后面，两个月后回去，发现它依然留在床头后面。哦天哪。我把这件事讲给另一个摇滚巨星听，他说：“哦天哪，我惊呆了。”我说：“对，太恶心了。”他说：“不是那个，你是摇滚巨星啊。”
Rock stars. Don't wear underwear. That was, that was in 1983. And I went commando for the next 20 years because of that. No way. Yeah, absolutely. Anyway, at some point in that while I was on stage in the, the Hoy Theatre in Rotterdam, you remember those, do you remember Madonna's pointy bra?
摇滚巨星不穿内衣。那是……那是1983年的事。而我因为那句话，在接下来的20年里都不穿内衣。不会吧。对，绝对是的。总之，有一次在舞台上，在鹿特丹的阿霍伊体育馆，你还记得那些……你还记得麦当娜的尖锥胸衣吗？
Sure, of course. With the like the cone thing on them. Well, he'd made the same sort of corresponding pants for guys with the kind of cones on the butt cheeks. And they had, and these two, instead of having one zip up the middle like normal trousers do, they had two zips, like one coming down from each hip, which meant they had a seam down the front. And so in between, right in between your legs was this kind of cross seam where all four bits of material joined up.
当然，记得。就是那种带圆锥造型的。好吧，他为男士们做了一款相对应的裤子，臀部位置也有那种圆锥。而且它们……这两条裤子不像普通裤子那样中间只有一条拉链，它们有两条拉链，从两边臀部各拉下来一条，这就意味着它们正中间有一条接缝。所以……在两腿之间、正正好好就是那个四块面料交汇的十字缝。
Anyway, I came running across to do my star jump in Hungry Like The Wolf where I jump off the rise and put my arms out like that. And I'd never worn these pants before. And the sweat on my knees kind of grabbed hold of the jeans material. I did the star and this seam in the middle of the crotch opened like a flower. And there's me and my junk flying towards the audience at velocity. And I'm thinking, holy shit. And all the girls are thinking, finally, this is what we've wanted forever.
总之，我当时朝台前跑过去，准备在《像狼一样饥饿》里做一个星跳，就是从升降台上跳下来，双臂像这样张开。我以前从没穿过这条裤子。我膝盖上的汗水不知怎么的黏住了牛仔布料。我做了个星跳，裤裆正中间的这条缝就像一朵花一样绽放了。然后就是我和我的宝贝以极高的速度朝着观众飞奔过去。我当时想，卧槽。所有的女孩都在想：终于来了，这就是我们等了一辈子的东西。
The horror. And I hit the stage and I actually managed to kind of cover up my modesty or cover myself modestly as just as the first flash bulb went off. Oh, wow. Running backstage, grabbing a towel and coming back out. And I did. Yes, I did. We had these little bar towels, these kind of like tartan bar towels on the stage.
太可怕了。我砸落在舞台上，居然在第一颗闪光灯亮起的瞬间，勉强把我的尴尬遮羞或者说体面地遮挡住了。哦，哇。跑回后台，抓起一条毛巾，然后又走了出来。我确实这么做了。是的，我照做了。舞台上有那种小酒吧毛巾，那种……那种格子花纹的酒吧毛巾。
I shoved one of those down the front of my waistband. And then I was very, very coy and very fey. Oh, I'm totally naked under here, everybody. What? I guess what I've got under here. Sean, do you have any of your pops? You know, Simon, you don't know this, but Sean, at one point decided he was going to be a pop star and he wrote a bunch of pop songs.
我把其中一条塞进了裤腰带前面。然后我表现得非常、非常害羞、非常矫揉造作：“哦，大家注意啦，我里面完全是真空的哦。什么？猜猜我里面穿了什么。”肖恩，你有准备什么流行歌曲吗？你知道的，西蒙，你可能不知道，肖恩曾经有一段时间决定要当个流行歌星，他写了一堆流行歌曲。
Yes, I did. Yes. And Sean, you don't have any of those handy, do you? Are you serious? Oh my God. Sean, just sing just for Simon because he's one of the great rock stars of all time. I love this. Ready?
是的，我写过。是的。肖恩，你身边没有留着那些歌谱吧？你是认真的吗？哦天哪。肖恩，就为西蒙唱一个吧，因为他是史上最伟大的摇滚巨星之一。我太喜欢这个了。准备好了吗？
Well, the lyrics are, isn't it rough enough without feeling the torture of love? Wow. There's music that could go to there. When she was five years old, my daughter Tallulah came up with this one. Oh my fucking God, I don't know what to do anymore. And I have to say, I prefer my daughters. Yeah, I get it. I get it.
歌词是这样的：“没有爱的折磨，生活难道还不够残酷吗？”哇。这音乐都可以直接配上了。当我的女儿塔鲁拉五岁的时候，她想出了这一句。哦，我他妈的，我不知道该怎么办了。我得说，我更喜欢我女儿写的。对，我懂。我懂。
I get it. But that wasn't bad. I'm being... Well, I'm not singing. I'm not doing it. It's so embarrassing. These guys will hear it, but nobody anywhere ever has heard these songs. And now the world will.
我懂。但那也不算太坏。我正在……好吧，我才不唱呢。我才不干。太尴尬了。这些家伙会听到，但世界上从来没有任何其他人听过这些歌。而现在全世界都要听到了。
And now the world's going to hear. Yeah. I'm honored. Simon, I know that we've kept you too long and you've got to go. Again, what an unbelievable thrill to have you, man. Yeah, this is amazing. It's so great to meet you. You're such a massive fan of everything you've done all the way along.
现在全世界都要听到了。对。我很荣幸。西蒙，我知道我们留你太久了，你得走了。再次感谢，能拥有你做嘉宾简直是难以置信的震撼，老兄。对，这太棒了。很高兴认识你。我是你一路走来所有作品的超级大粉丝。
The best luck of the new album. We didn't even get to the... Future past? To the boat crash. We didn't even get to the... We didn't even get to that. We'll have to do that next time. The nautical disaster.
祝你的新专辑大获成功。我们甚至还没聊到……《未来过去》？那起沉船事故。我们甚至都没聊到……我们甚至都没聊到那个。我们下次得聊聊那个。那场航海灾难。
Come back and I'll tell you all about the boat disaster. If you want me back. I would love it. We would love it. We want you back repeatedly. Thank you. Part two. Part two with Simon Laban is coming somewhat sometime soon.
等你再来，我会把那场船难的经历全告诉你。如果你还想让我来的话。我求之不得。我们求之不得。我们想让你一而再、再而三地来。谢谢。第二部分。西蒙·勒·邦做客的第二部分不久后就会上线。
And we're going to talk about the nautical disaster. In the meantime, we've just enjoyed having you so much, man. Yeah. Thanks for stopping by. It's been a huge pleasure. Thank you, fellas. Thank you, Simon. See you soon.
我们将聊聊那场航海灾难。在此期间，有你做客我们真的太开心了，老兄。对。谢谢你抽空前来。这真的是巨大的荣幸。谢谢你们，伙计们。谢谢你，西蒙。回头见。
Come and see us on tour. We're really good. Yeah, for sure. Bye. Bye-bye. We're really good. Sean, you know, again, as an aspiring pop star, can you imagine young Sean Hayes, who had written...
来看我们的巡演吧。我们现场真的很棒。对，一定的。拜拜。拜拜。我们真的很棒。肖恩，你知道的，作为一个有抱负的流行歌星，你能想象年轻的肖恩·海斯曾经写过……
He's got a handful of songs written on the backs of what I'm guessing are napkins. It's so... These songs are so... By the way, I wrote these songs with Jordan Roseman, who's known as DJ Earworm now. No way. Yeah. Do you know DJ Earworm? Of course, you did that.
他写了几首歌在……我猜是餐巾纸的背面。太……这些歌太……顺便说一句，这些歌是我和乔丹·罗斯曼一起写的，他现在被称为“DJ耳虫”。不会吧。对。你知道DJ耳虫吗？当然，你做过那个。
The mash-ups. All those mash-ups. Yeah. Oh, yeah. So I wrote all these songs with him. And... By the way, this is so bizarre. I sent these songs to Bennett and Rob last night just to have, like, right?
那些混音。所有的那些混音。对。哦，是的。所以这些歌都是我和他一起写的。而且……顺便说一句，这太诡异了，我昨晚把这些歌发给了本尼特和罗布，就是为了……对吧？
Just so we could... I could play them for you guys. I didn't know Simon Laban, obviously, was going to be on today. No, and I didn't know that you would send them to Bennett and Rob. I did not connect with them. Oh, really? This was not a setup. No.
就是为了……我可以放给你们听。我当时并不知道西蒙·勒·邦今天会来。不，而且我也不知道你会把这些歌发给本尼特和罗布。我跟他们没对过。哦，真的吗？这不是安排好的。不。
Oh, I thought maybe you heard that. But I remember when you were saying that you had them, you called me after we talked about them one time and you said, I found all those songs. Can we just hear a little bit, please? Okay, so... So we'll play, like, a little bit of the song. No, this is terrible. Hang on.
哦，我还以为你提前听说了呢。但当我听到你说你留着那些歌时，我们在聊过一次之后你打电话给我说，我找到那些存底的歌了。我们能听一小段吗，求你了？好吧，所以……所以我们要放一小段这首歌。不，这太可怕了。等等。
Shut up. Listen to my chipmunk vibrato. Shh. Cause I wanted to sound like the Peshman. Oh, my god. It felt like a goat getting hammered. Wait a second. Wait a second.
闭嘴。听听我那花栗鼠般的颤音。嘘。因为我想模仿“赶时髦”乐队。哦，天哪。听起来就像一只挨了锤的山羊。等一下。等一下。
Wait a second. Wait a minute. Here comes the drop. Here comes the drop. That's right. And you're in shorts with suspenders, no shirt. Leader Hosun. There's the drop. Oh my god, it's so 80s.
等一下。高潮要来了。高潮要来了。没错。然后你穿着带背带的短裤，没穿上衣。莉萨·霍森。高潮来了。哦天哪，太80年代了。
Glowstick in the teeth, and now we're dancing. You didn't want to be professional. You were trying to be Andy Bell. Let's be real. You were trying to be a racer. I was totally trying to be a racer. And we can cut that now. That sounds pretty great. What are you singing? The words are so bad.
牙齿上咬着荧光棒，然后我们开始跳舞。你根本不想当专业歌手。你当时是在试图模仿安迪·贝尔。说实话吧。你当时是在试图模仿“伊莱休”乐队。我完全是在试图模仿“伊莱休”。我们可以把这段剪掉。听起来还挺不错的。你在唱什么？这歌词太烂了。
It's like, I walk the road. I walk the road. Between my happiness and despair. Like what? How old were you when you were writing this? 20. There should be some sort of reward program for diehard smart listeners.
就像是，我走在路上。我走在路上。在我的幸福和绝望之间。这都什么跟什么？你写这歌的时候几岁？20岁。真该为那些死忠的精明听众设立某种奖励计划。
How many songs are there? There's two that are done. And then two that are kind of... They should be able to get those two songs. Now, if I could say to you... No, anyway, no fucking anyway. Hang on a second. How happy would you be if we dropped your tunes?
一共有多少首歌？有两首是完成的。还有两首算是……他们应该有资格听到那两首完整的歌。现在，如果我对你说……不，总之，去他妈的总之。等一下。如果我们把你的这些曲子放出来，你会有多高兴？
But we brought in, and here are some of the names who are going to come in and sing and we re-record them. You ready? It's going to be you, Andy Bell, obviously. Oh my god, I would fucking die. I would love that. He's like my hero. Andy Bell's the lead singer of Erasure. And also we're going to get... We're just talking about from Erasure the other...
但我们请来了……以下是一些即将登台献唱并重新录制这些歌的嘉宾名字。准备好了吗？主唱肯定是你，安迪·贝尔，毫无疑问。哦天哪，我他妈当场去世。我会爱死那样的。他是我的偶像。安迪·贝尔是“伊莱休”乐队的主唱。而且我们还要请到……我们刚刚还在聊“伊莱休”的另一个……
Oh, Vince Clark. Vince Clark, one of the founding members of the Pesh Mode and who founded Erasure. And Yazz. And also Yazz with Alison Moyet. So we're going to get Vince Clark. We're going to get Andy Bell, so everybody from Erasure. We're going to get...
哦，文斯·克拉克。文斯·克拉克，“赶时髦”乐队的创始成员之一，也是“伊莱休”的创始人。还有亚兹。还有亚兹搭档爱莉森·莫耶特。所以我们要请到文斯·克拉克。我们要请到安迪·贝尔，也就是“伊莱休”全员。我们要请到……
How are you going to get these people? Martin Gore. Dave Gahan. And we're going to have Simon, and we're going to have... What's his name? I'm from... Who actually did Band-Aid 2 when they did a second one in 1989. Jimmy Somerville was on that.
你们怎么请得到这些人？马丁·戈尔。戴夫·加汉。我们还要请到西蒙，我们还要请到……那叫什么来着？我是从……谁在1989年他们搞第二次义演时真正参与了“拯救生命”第二版？吉米·萨莫维尔也参加了那个。
Yeah, yeah, that's right. I don't know all this. Because... Will is like showing me a side of his Canadian youth. Do you have one of those mopeds with the raccoon tail and everything? No, I was... I wrote around like I was in Quadrophenia, you know, with the long parka.
对，对，没错。我可不知道这些。因为……威尔就像是在向我展示他加拿大青春期的一面。你是不是也有一辆挂着浣熊尾巴之类的轻便摩托车？不，我……我骑车到处晃，就像在演《四重人格》那样，穿着长款派克大衣。
No, I didn't have that. I was a huge Smiths fan, obviously. Huge, yeah. We listened to the exact same music going up. I know, I know. That's crazy. Wait, so yeah, no, but it was... I'm so glad we didn't play that while Simon was on.
不，我没有那个。我显然是“史密斯”乐队的超级粉丝。超级粉丝，对。我们成长过程中听的音乐完全一模一样。我懂，我懂。太疯狂了。等等，所以，不，不过……我很庆幸我们在西蒙在的时候没放这段。
We waited till it's up. I mean, Simon Laban, when I remember seeing that video for like Hungry Like the Wolf and Rio, and he talks about nerves, he was so confident. That was the other thing. Everybody in the band was so confident and cool, and they were kind of doing...
我们等他走了才放。我是说，西蒙·勒·邦，当我回想起看《像狼一样饥饿》和《里约》的MV时，他表现得那么自信。那是另一回事。乐队里的每个人都那么自信、那么酷，他们当时……
They were wearing mascara in their things, and they were just kind of like... They were just like... It's also the start of MTV. It was really the first time our generation really got a look at rock stars and what they do and how they do it. But they weren't a boy band in the sense that...
他们在脸上涂着睫毛膏，而且他们就那种……他们就像是……这也是MTV诞生的时期。那真的是我们这一代人第一次真正看到摇滚巨星是什么样、他们在做什么以及他们是怎么做到的。但他们又不是那种意义上的男孩乐队……
No offense, but they were actual musicians, and they were actually really good and handsome. They weren't like a corporate transaction. No, those guys formed... I mean, they all kind of came together, put ads out in Melody Maker magazine, and they met each other and had a bar,
无意冒犯，但他们是真正的音乐人，而且他们确实非常有才华、长得又帅。他们不是那种商业运作出来的产品。不，那些家伙是自己组建的……我的意思是，他们都是通过在《旋律制造者》杂志上登广告聚到一起的，他们遇到了彼此，还在一家酒吧里……
and they formed the band, and they worked at the bar. They really earned it and wrote all these great songs. But it's a testament that that's why they have longevity, I think, right? Because they're the real deal. I'd love to hear their new album and see how their musical styles have changed.
然后他们组建了乐队，还在那家酒吧打过工。他们真的是靠实力赢得了这一切，并写出了所有这些伟大的歌曲。但这恰恰证明了为什么他们能够长盛不衰，对吧？因为他们是货真价实的。我很想听听他们的新专辑，看看他们的音乐风格发生了怎样的变化。
I mean, they had hit records, hit records, hit records, and they break up, do other things, and they come back, and then like 10 years later have another huge smash hit record in the middle 90s with the wedding album. They just keep doing it. Yeah, it's a testament. You're going to their show when they come here, yeah?
我的意思是，他们一首接一首地出热门单曲，解散后各自去发展，然后重聚，在10年后的90年代中期又凭《婚礼专辑》轰动一时。他们一直在创作。对，这就是证明。你这次会去看他们来这里的演唱会吧，对吧？
Oh, for sure. I didn't know that they were at the Hollywood Bowl last year, and somebody said to me like, well, you're definitely going to Duran Duran, right? I was like, what? Yeah, I'm going to that. I'm going to Depeche Mode in September. I was out of town. We're going to Depeche Mode together. Depeche Mode is playing in September?
哦，当然。我之前不知道他们去年在好莱坞露天剧场演出，然后有人对我说，嘿，你肯定会去看杜兰杜兰的演出，对吧？我说，什么？对，我要去。我九月份还要去看“赶时髦”乐队。我当时刚好不在城里。我们要一起去看“赶时髦”。“赶时髦”九月份有演出？
I know every word. I love Depeche Mode. And one of my biggest regrets, we both know. I think I'm looking at one right now with that sweater. Just look at your hair. One of my biggest regrets. We both swung hard at that one show.
我每句歌词都会唱。我太喜欢“赶时髦”了。而且我最大的遗憾之一，我们俩都知道。我想我正看着其中一个穿着那件毛衣的人呢。看看你的发型就知道了。我最大的遗憾之一。我们俩当时对那场演出可是势在必得。
You can't get a softball by us. Go ahead, Will. I mean, Jesus Christ. Thank God I'm batting clean up in this crew, you know what I mean? We're so eager. In 1995, God, I might have messed up on the date. But it's so hurtful still to this day.
你们可从我们这儿讨不到半点便宜。继续吧，威尔。我是说，天哪。幸好我是这支队伍里的压轴主力，你知道我的意思吗？我们太渴望了。在1995年，天哪，我可能把日期记错了。但直到今天想起来还是觉得好伤心。
I had the ability to go see the Smiths play. One of their only shows they ever did in Canada. And I couldn't go because I had to leave with my family. And I was like, can we just, can I just stay an extra day to see them? They were playing at Canada's Wonderland outside of Toronto. Wow. And I couldn't go see them.
我本来有机会去看“史密斯”乐队的演出。那是他们在加拿大举办的仅有的几场演出之一。但我去不了，因为我得跟家人一起离开。当时我还说，我们能不能……我能不能多留一天去看他们？他们当时在多伦多郊区的加拿大奇幻乐园演出。哇。结果我没能去看。
In 95? Yeah, 85. Go be with my family for the summer. And then, of course, in two years, they released The Queen is Dead, then they break up after that. Thanks, Jim. Thanks, Alex. But anyway, I want to stay in their present
95年？对，85年。去和家人过夏天。然后，当然，两年后他们就发布了《女王已死》，之后他们就解散了。谢谢你，吉姆。谢谢你，亚历克斯。不过不管怎样，我还是想活在当下
because I don't want to spend a lot of time talking about buy guns. Buy guns. Buy guns. Buy. Smart. Smart. Smart.
因为我不想花太多时间去聊“买枪”。买枪。买枪。买。精明。精明。精明。
Smart. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbacow, and Michael Grandtari. Smart. Our next episode will be out in a week
精明。SmartLess 是由罗布·阿尔朱夫、本尼特·巴尔巴考和迈克尔·格兰特里 100% 有机手工打造的。Smart。我们的下一集将在四周后发布
wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon Music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus Apple Podcasts or the Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以通过任何你听播客的地方收听，或者现在就在亚马逊音乐上抢先收听，也可以订阅“Wondry Plus”、苹果播客或 Wondery App 来享受抢先收听和无广告体验。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。